thank you James Surowiecki writes the
financial page column for The New Yorker
he looks at how groupthink impacts our
culture in his new book the wisdom of
crowds this talks an hour our guest
tonight James Surowiecki
the business columnist for The New
Yorker magazine has authored a
fascinating study about an idea the idea
that groups of people
crowds are often smarter as a whole than
the smartest person in them entitled the
wisdom of crowds this book is to quote a
reviewer dazzling please welcome James
Sora Ikki thank you thank you so what I
thought I'd do is I'm gonna read for
maybe well-read slash kind of talk about
the book for 20 to 25 minutes and then
I'll take questions for a while I think
it's the sort of book that when you hear
about it and just hear a little bit of
it ideas and questions some skeptical
some supportive will come to mind and
it's a it's not a very long book tell me
about it's about 300 pages but it covers
a lot of ground and I'm not gonna try to
summarize the whole book because the one
time I try to do that I there were some
glazed eyes in the audience so what I'm
really gonna do is I'm going to read
from the introduction and sort of try to
give you a sense of what of what what's
in the book and then we could talk more
after that so I want to start with the
book starts with the story of this
British scientist named Francis Galton
who is actually best known for the fact
that he was the founder of what's called
eugenics so he was someone who was a
kind of avowed elitist and who really
believed that breeding kind of made the
fundamental difference and that power
should really be concentrated in the
hand
very few people and the story that opens
the book is a story of Galt and coming
face to face with evidence that maybe
his basic assumptions about sort of
intelligence and ability were at best
deeply flawed so when he was 85 years
old he was he had he lived in London but
he had gone to the West of England to
sort of rest essentially and on this one
day he went to a what was the equivalent
of a State Fair was it was called the
West of England fat stock and poultry
exhibition this was just a place where
you know the local farmers and talents
people would come and they would
appraise each other's livestock and
poultry and sheep etc so that's that's
he starts walking through the exhibition
that's where we pick up as you walk
through the exhibition that day Galt
inque Macross a wait judging competition
a fat ox had been selected and placed on
display and members of a gathering crowd
were lined up to place wagers on the
weight of the Ox now they're actually
placing wagers on the weight of the Ox
after it had been slaughtered and
dressed so they were sort of predicting
what the Oxford weigh after he'd been
butchered for sixpence you could buy a
stamp to number ticket where you filled
it filled in your name your address and
your estimate the best guesses would
receive prizes 800 people tried their
luck they were a diverse lot many of
them were butchers and farmers who were
presumably expert at judging the weight
of livestock but there are also quite a
few people who had as it were no insider
knowledge of cattle many non-experts
competed Galt enroll ATAR in the
scientific journal Nature like those
clerks and others who have no expert
knowledge of horses but who bet on races
guided by newspapers friends and their
own fancies the analogy to a democracy
in which people have radically different
abilities and interests each get one
vote suggested itself to 'golden
immediately now but Gong was interested
in figuring out what the average voter
was capable of that's what he sort of
saw this contest is potentially
demonstrating because what he wanted to
prove was that the average voter was
capable of very little so he turned the
competition into an impromptu experiment
when the contest was over and the prizes
have been awarded
Dalton borrowed the tickets from the
organizers and he ran a series of
statistical tests on them
he arranged the guesses in the end there
were about 787 in all he arranged them
in order from highest to lowest he
graphed them to see if they formed a
bell curve he wanted to know if the
distribution was what mathematicians
call normal and then among other things
he added all the contestants estimates
together and he calculated the mean of
the group's guesses that number
represented you could say or I will say
the collective wisdom of the plymouth
crowd
if the crowd were a single person that
was how much it would have guessed the
Ox weighed gaunt and undoubtedly thought
that the average guess of the group
would be way off the mark
after all makes a few very smart people
with what he thought were some mediocre
people and a lot of dumb people and it
seems likely that you'd end up with a
dumb answer but Galton's wrong the
crowded guests at the Ox after it had
been slaughtered and dressed would weigh
1197 pounds and after it had been
slaughtered and dressed the Ox weighed
1198 pounds in other words the crowds
judgment was essentially perfect perhaps
breeding did not mean so much after all
what Francis Galton's stumbled on that
day in Plymouth was not some quirk
relating to the guessing of the weight
of oxen or livestock in general instead
it was a simple truth and it's the truth
that is at the heart of the book which
is that under the right circumstances
groups are remarkably intelligent and
are often smarter than the smartest
people in them groups do not need to be
dominated by exceptionally intelligent
people in order to be smart even if most
of the people within a group are not
especially well-informed or rational it
can still reach a collectively wise
decision and this of course is a good
thing because human beings are not
perfectly designed to design decision
makers if you ever read a sort of if you
ever took an econ 10 class or read an
economics textbook economists often make
a series of assumptions about the way
individuals are and they do so for good
reason it helps them construct models
that are actually quite useful in
thinking about the way economies work
but the assumptions they make about
human beings don't have much to do with
the way human beings really are
economists assume human beings are
perfectly rational or not they assume
human beings have what they call perfect
information we don't
we have limited foresight into the
future most of us lacked the ability and
the desire to make sophisticated
cost-benefit calculations instead of
insisting on finding the best possible
decision we will often accept one that
seems good enough instead of hunting all
over creation to find out the exact best
price will say well this seems pretty
good so we'll accept that and we often
of course let emotion affect our
judgment but despite all these
limitations when our imperfect judgments
are aggregated in the right way our
collective intelligence is often
excellent now much of the book obviously
is devoted to showing this in some in
some detail actually in quite a bit of
detail but let me give you a few
examples of kind of concrete concrete
ways in this within which this manifests
itself the Ox weight guessing problem is
obviously a very simple one but the
wisdom of crowds can be used to self and
is used to solve far more complicated
problems one great example is an
internet search engine Google the way
Google fundamentally finds the pages
that have the information you want is
roughly speaking by asking every web
page on the Internet to vote as to which
pages are most valuable it does that by
treating each link you know they're
hyperlinks from one page to another as a
vote and it sort of weights the votes in
a certain way and there it considers a
whole other series of factors but but at
its heart the technology that drives
drives google is based on this idea that
if you ask a large crowd of in this case
web pages the answer to a problem that
has a definitive answer you will end up
with a with a truly excellent answer and
at least from my experience Google does
so remarkably often a couple weeks ago I
wrote a column for The New Yorker about
Google bombing which is really the
attempt of people to manipulate Google
and as I was trying to illustrate the
fact that Google was really good most of
the time at finding information you know
the key is not that it returns 125,000
pages it's that the the pages on that
first page on Google's first page are
really the ones you're looking for so I
did a search on Abu Ghraib the Iraqi
prison and the first page that came up
with Seymour Hersh cos first article in
The New Yorker which as far as I'm
concerned is the piece you probably want
to start
reading if you wanted to know what was
going on and you know there was no guy
sitting in a room at Google saying well
this is the piece everyone's talking
about so this is the one you should link
to that was just the result of this you
know sort of seemingly chaotic system
anybody can set up a website anyone can
hyperlink to whatever they want and the
result is is brilliant another great
example and one that I probably will
come back to in the course of this is
the racetrack at the racetrack the odds
on horses predict almost to a tee how
likely a horse is to win so if you look
at say a hundred races horses that go
off at three-to-one odds they win about
a quarter of the time which is exactly
what the crowd is predicting and what's
interesting about that is of course a
lot of people at the racetrack know what
they're doing they're reading a Daily
Racing Form they're you know fully
invested but of course they're often a
lot of people to racetrack who are
betting on horses because they like the
name or because you know they they think
the jockey is or because they've gotten
hot tip or whatever it is and the other
thing is to think about what the crowd
is doing in that case is that the crowd
is really forecasting the future and
it's forecasting a future that basically
involves animals note notoriously high
strong animals who are turned ridden by
human beings who have you know a series
of different issues and are often
corrupt etc etc and yet it's able
roughly speaking to predict exactly the
outcomes it beyond the the straight odds
it's also the case that the favorite
horses win most often second favorite
horses win second most often third
favorite I'd say straight down the line
another sort of simple anecdotal piece
of evidence there are a series of
experiments that were done by American
sociologists between the 1920s and the
1950s demonstrating this phenomenon and
these these experiments are actually
quite similar to the Ox waying
experiment a simple one is that if if I
had a jar of July think there are enough
people here now if I had a jar of
jellybeans up here and asked you all the
guests the average guess how many
jellybeans were in the jar the group's
gas would be within one or two percent
of the right number and it would be
better than just about everybody in the
group so these are a series there's a
there and there the book goes on and
talks about a series of other ones that
another obvious one but a much more
complicated example is the stock market
where it's very difficult for even
professional money managers to
outperform the market now stock markets
as we know are far from perfect and
there's a good deal in the book about
how stock markets go to extremes but
over time the stock market probably does
provide I think a pretty good estimate
of the future value of companies the
task that's that investors are being
asked to perform is incredibly difficult
so even good answers are not always
right on the money
but that's that's another example of
this so the the way the book is
structured in the book serve works on
two levels in a way as the example
suggests one of the things that I'm
trying to do in the book is describe the
world as it is and there are a lot of
things in the book that have to do with
kind of everyday life so there's other
sections about the way crowds move down
a city street and there's a chapter
about traffic and I try to explain why
people pay their taxes and and I think
that the wisdom of crowds obviously
underlies a lot of the most fundamental
systems that we rely on it underlies the
market word that we in some way I think
it probably underlies democracy and so I
hope we can the book allows you to look
at things that seem very different and
say well actually there's this common
thread between them but the book is also
about the world as it might be one of
the striking things about the wisdom of
crowds is that even though its effects
are all around us
it's easy to miss and even when it's
seen it can be hard to accept I think
we're not collectively we're not
collectively intelligent about our own
collective intelligence if you can think
if that makes sense
most of us whether it's voters or
investors or consumers or managers
believe that valuable knowledge is
concentrated in a very few hands we
assume that the key to solving problems
or making good decisions is finding that
one right person who will have the
answer and even when we see a large
crowd of people many of them not
especially well-informed do something
amazing like say predict the outcome of
horse races we're more likely to
attribute that success to a few smart
people in the crowd than to the crowd
itself as sociologist Jack B saw and
Richard Larrick put it we feel the need
to quote chase the expert the argument
of the book is that chasing the expert
is a mistake and and it's a costly one
much of the time we should really stop
hunting and ask the crowd instead and of
course the crowd includes all the smart
people too it's not a question of you
know
including smart people but if you ask
the crowd the likelihood of getting a
consistently good answer is better so
now Charles Mackay would have scoffed at
the idea that a crowd of people could
have known anything at all
Mackay is as some of you probably know
was the Scottish journalist who in 1841
published extraordinary popular
delusions in the madness of crowds which
is this endlessly entertaining chronicle
of mass manias and collective follies
and the title of the book is in homage
to two McKay's from Mackay crowds were
never wise they were never even
reasonable collective judgments were
doomed to be extreme men it has been
well said thinking herds it will be seen
that they go mad in herds and while they
only recover their senses slowly and one
by one McKay's take on collective
madness is not an unusual one in the
popular imagination groups tend to make
people either dumb or crazy or both so
you either have the lynch mob and the
stock market bubble or else you have the
sort of you know lowest common
denominator everything's getting watered
down Menken saying no one in this world
has ever lost money by under estimating
the intelligence of the great masses of
the plain people those are the sort of
two images the speculator Bernard Baruch
said anyone taken as an individual is
tolerably sensible and reasonable as a
member of a crowd he at once becomes a
blockhead Thoreau said the mass never
comes up to the standard of its best
member but on the contrary degrades
itself to a level with the lowest
perhaps the most severe critic of the
stupidity of groups was the French
writer Gustave Lebon who in 1895
published the polemical classic the
crowd a study of the popular mind Lebon
like a lot of the xix of the 19th
century critics was appalled by the rise
of democracy in the West in the 19th
century and he was dismayed by the idea
that ordinary people had come to wield
political cultural and even to a certain
extent economic power you know the
market for all of its limitations was
fundamentally open especially in the
19th century you were witnessing and
landed aristocracy being replaced by
merchants who had no breeding but who
were for whatever reason successful
Labonte's disdain for groups was was so
deep that he it wasn't just sort of the
the obvious extreme crowds that he
thought were bad he actually thought
that
also included any group that could make
decisions and he wrote in crowds at his
stupidity and not mother wit that is
accumulated Sola Bangla met lame lamb
basted juries Humana basted Parliament's
and he said if you have assembled smart
people who were specialist in a host of
different fields and asked them to make
decisions affecting matters of general
interest the decisions they would reach
would be no better on the whole than
those quote adopted by a gathering of
imbeciles so over the course of the book
I follow the bonds lead and giving the
words group and crowd broad definitions
so crowds really is using and group are
using the book and really capacious
sense I I talk about everything from
game show audiences The Who Wants to Be
a Millionaire audience when you when
they're asked the question you know the
when you get stumped on Who Wants to Be
a Millionaire you can you can ask an
expert that you've nominated for help or
you can ask the audience audience gets
the answer right 91 percent of the time
and the experts get the answer right 65
percent of the time we can have you
there are statistical quibbles you can
make about the difficulty of the
questions but it's still quite striking
I think I used I talk about
multibillion-dollar corporations as I
said crowds of sports gamblers traffic
jams etc some of the groups in this book
like management teams or boards of
directors are tightly organized and very
much aware of their identities as groups
other crowds like the herds of crowd
caught in traffic have no formal
organization at all and still others
like investors in a stock market exist
mainly as an ever-changing collection of
numbers and dollars these groups are all
different but what they have in common
is the ability to act collectively to
make decisions and solve problems and to
do that even when the individuals don't
really know that's what's going on an
investor who's buying or selling a stock
is not trying to make the group as a
whole smarter but collectively the
market is reaching decisions about how
capital be allocated it you know etc etc
and and what's demonstrable true of some
of these groups namely that they are
very smart and they are good at problem
solving and decision making I think is
potentially true of most if not all of
them and in that sense Lebon had things
exactly backward if you put together a
big enough and diverse enough group of
people and ask them to make decisions
affecting matters of general interest
that's how he phrased it that groups
decisions will be over
I'm intellectually superior to the
isolated individual no matter how smart
or well-informed he is now I said big
enough and diverse enough and those two
things are important because there there
are a number of conditions under which
groups work well and and when they're
absent that's really what I think you
really run into problems and two of the
most important conditions are diversity
and independence diversity is essential
because and divert by diversity I mean
you want diverse sources of opinion
diverse information diverse attitudes so
I'm not really talking necessarily about
sociological diversity although you can
make the case in some societies there's
probably a connection between
sociological diversity and cognitive
ersity but so we're really talking about
diverse opinions and that speaks to
another important point which is that
when I talk about collective wisdom
we're not talking about consensus or
compromise which i think is one when we
hear about group decision-making a lot
of us visualize teams or committees
we've sat on where you know two things
either one of two things happens either
the leader has made his decision and
then solicits people's opinions to kind
of get buy-in so you know people can
have the illusion that they have
contributed in some way or the group is
striving for consensus and so you spend
all your time trying to find the thing
on which you can agree and that's really
how collective decisions get watered
down that's not really what I'm talking
about here at all in fact the best
collective decisions are the product of
disagreement and contest not consensus
and compromise an intelligent group
especially when confronted with problems
that have say a right answer or where
one answer is better than others like
you know the horse race or if you're a
corporation what should what product
should we invest in what what are the
chances of this product taking off in
the market an intelligent group in the
face of those problems does not ask its
members to modify their positions in
order to let the group reach a decision
that everyone can be happy with instead
it figures out how to use mechanisms
like say market prices or the Google's
algorithm or voting systems to aggregate
and produce collective judgments that
represent in a sense not what any one
person in the group necessarily thinks
but but what they all think that's sort
of the idea much of the time that the
final outcome will be something that
one person does think but ideally you
want to produce truly collective
judgments and so paradoxically the best
way for a group to be smart is for each
person in it to think and act as
independently as possible
now this isn't easy a lot of the book is
devoted to bad group decision making
small groups in particular it's very
difficult because you have all these
personal dynamics you have people want
to go along to get along because there's
a certain value in unity in small groups
oftentimes leaders play an inordinately
influential role in groups or actually
even people who talk a lot often shape
the group's decisions in ways that maybe
are not best and and even in large
groups independence is a real problem by
independence what I mean is not it is
that people make their decisions
relatively speaking on their own so you
know of course you're going to be
getting information and talking to
people around you but when you make that
decision you're really trying to do it
it's reflecting what you think rather
than either a what you think other
people think or B what happens in a
stock market which is that you start to
say well no if this stock is really
worth this but I'm pretty sure that five
months from now I'm gonna be able to
dump it on you know that guy over there
so you start hunting for the greater
fool when when crowds get caught in that
kind of dynamic then their collective
decisions are not going to be
intelligent and I think what happened in
the late nineteen nineties for instance
in the internet stock market bubble is
that neither diversity nor independence
was present diversity disappeared
because the drumbeat in favor of the
internet and the new economy and
basically you know buy on the dips was
so powerful that there was really only
one message being heard and independence
disappeared because in stock market
bubbles what happens is that everyone
starts just feeding the process feeds on
itself and people start thinking not
about what the true value is but about
what everyone else will think the true
value is so those two things are really
essential the other thing that's really
important is that you want people to be
decentralized you know you want you
don't want to obviously a top-down
leadership telling people how to think
but you have to have some means of
putting all those individual collective
judgments together now this sounds kind
of obvious but if you think about for
instance the
and American intelligence community both
arguably before 9/11 but certainly
before Iraq I think there's a strong
argument to be made that you're talking
there about a community that was
decentralized so you had people that
were out there gathering information
from many different sources and we know
you know how many different agencies
there are but there was really no
mechanism for putting all those
different judgments into one in a sense
for putting all those judgments together
so you really need not just the
decentralization you also need a way to
it sounds obvious but it's something
that I think it's it's easy to sort of
skip over you can't just kind of throw
people out there and trust that that
good things are gonna are gonna come of
it okay I'm about done reading but I'm
gonna finish with well I began the
introduction I began with this with this
with a simple problem which is figuring
out the weight of the ox and I'm gonna
end it with an example of a group
solving an incredibly complex problem
locating a lost submarine the
differences between these two cases are
immense but I would argue and the idea
behind the book is that the principle in
each case is exactly the same okay so in
May 1968 the u.s. submarine scorpion
disappeared on its way back to Newport
News after a tour of duty in the North
Atlantic
although the Navy knew the subs last
reported location it had no idea what
had happened to the Scorpion and only
the vaguest sense of how far it might
have traveled after did last made radio
contact as a result the area where the
Navy began searching for the Scorpion
was a circle 20 miles wide and many
thousands of feet deep you could not
imagine a more hopeless task but a naval
officer named John Craven thought he had
an idea about how to find the summary
and he convinced the Navy people to let
him do it
so first Craven concocted a series of
scenarios these were alternative
explanations for what might have
happened to the Scorpion because
remember the Navy didn't even have any
idea why it had gone down then he
assembled a team of men with a wide
range of knowledge including
mathematicians submarine specialists
salvage men so they were a diverse group
of people they were certainly
knowledgeable in their own fields but
but he wanted to assemble a diverse
group and then instead of asking him to
consult with each other to come up with
an answer
he asked each of them to offer his best
guess about how likely each of the
scenarios was and to keep things
interesting the guesses were done in the
form of way
with bottles of Shiva's regal as prizes
so so Cravens men bet they bet on why
the submarine ran into trouble on its
speed as it headed to the ocean bottom
on the steepness of its descent and so
on needless to say no one of these
pieces of information could tell Kraven
where the Scorpion was but Craven
thought that if he put all the answers
together and built a kind of composite
picture of how the Scorpion died he'd
end up with a pretty good idea of where
it had ended up on the ocean floor and
so that's exactly what he did he took
the various wagers and he used a formula
called Bayes theorem to estimate the
scorpions final location well I can
explain what base theorem is if you need
to but I think we can skip it when he
was done Kraven had what was roughly
speaking the group's collective estimate
of where the submarine was what's
interesting is that the location the
Craven came up with was not a spot that
any individual member of the group had
picked in other words no no one member
of the group had a picture in his head
that matched the one Craven had
constructed using the information
gathered from all of them the final
estimate was a genuinely collective
judgment that the group as a whole had
made as opposed as opposed to
representing the individual judgment of
the smartest people in it sometimes I
think when you hear the idea of the
wisdom of crowds it can be interpreted
as saying simply well if you ask enough
people you increase your chances of
finding the one person who has the right
answer that's not what we're talking
about here this is this is a genuinely
collective judgment in which in a sense
the group as a whole had this idea that
no individual could the group's judgment
was also genuinely brilliant five months
after the scorpion disappeared a navy
ship found it and it was 220 yards from
where Cravens group had said it would be
but what's astonishing about this story
is that the evidence on which the group
was was relying amount it's almost
nothing it was really just tiny scraps
of data no one knew why the submarine
sank no one had any idea how fast it was
traveling or how steeply had fallen to
the ocean floor and yet even though no
one in the group knew any of these
things the group as a whole
knew them all so that's that's that
okay good good perfect so if any of you
have questions about anything yeah good
we sort of lead our lives using cues I
think you know it yes and there's a fair
amount of scholarship that would you
address that as it fits in to you know
like you buy a bottle of milk and you
think it's safe right you drink that's a
cube right and and so our whole life is
made up of a few right does that enter
into years yeah I think it enters in in
two in two different ways
it actually is it makes group decisions
more complicated because I think it gets
to the independence question because one
of the cues we look at is actually what
other people are doing that they're
that's a kind of easy heuristic I mean I
use in the book I use the example of I
live in Brooklyn and you have to park
your car you don't have to move your car
on Tuesdays or Thursdays and because of
street street cleaning and you have to
move your car by 11:00 they should clean
the street between 11:00 and 2:00 so if
I walk out of my house at 10:45 and all
the cars on the street where my car is
you know with that that normally would
be gone are still there I know that that
for whatever reason street cleaning has
been suspended I just assumed that the
group that in this case people are you
know smart enough someone's been
following the thing and I think a lot of
cues that we follow actually like that
there's a great story in the book about
this so you may have heard of this
experiment where these social scientists
put started off by they put two or three
people on the corner looking up at the
sky and then of course it's pretty
quickly a small group would gather and
then as you increase the group of people
looking more people look so that by the
time you remember how many people they
put out there maybe you don't say 10 or
15 people something like 80% of the
people walking by stop then we're just
gazing up at the sky and then I think
the other cues we look at our more there
are sort of you know yeah the market is
a good example you know brands are proud
our way of using
so you know if Sony makes something we
assume it's relatively reliable etc I
think the key in general is that if you
have enough people in the group who are
doing kind of prospecting on their own
and are willing to look beyond the queue
are willing to change their mind if the
queue doesn't work then I think the
groups can still reach collectively
intelligent decisions and I also have
some faith that actually queues work to
the extent that they're useful and when
they stop being useful they tend to be
abandoned but one interesting example I
may not be exactly what you're thinking
about but is price is an interesting
example of this because obviously most
people who shop don't really look for
the best price exactly
I mean everyone has some kind of sense
and if you go into store it's insanely
expensive you won't buy but most people
don't you know actively go out and
search for the best price but what's
pretty clear from experiments and theory
is that you only need a relatively small
percentage of really ardent bargain
hunters for the market as a whole to
reach kind of what would be the
equivalent of everyone was and that's
because you know the competition will
essentially drive down so that's that's
that's one example yeah I don't question
about effective use of crowds if I'm a
leader the president of son or governor
I would like to create a crowd of people
to advise me yeah and I understand it
want people with independent judgments
and diversity but then I would want to
make the decision
myself and I think I would do a better
job but what I want to make sure is that
I got interesting information that I
cook but I wouldn't count getting
another hundred thousand people right
the mix once I had say 15 yes lived in
hell yeah and as long as somebody
she did and I sort of see reminded I
think of you as a journalist when you're
writing your articles you're not gonna
try and seek out large crowds of reckful
you want diversity you want independence
right and then you want to make the
judgement well I would actually I mean I
think that the last part is the real
question I have a chapter here on the
corporation and I actually think
companies should literally allow not
necessarily retired employees but I
think companies should experiment with
allowing you know crowds of different
sorts you would say say the crowd of
vice-presidents or however you wanted to
set up the cadre to actually make
concrete decisions oh go ahead no please
that's to make sure that you don't miss
a piece of data I'm guessing I mean
that's what I'm most concerned about I'd
want to sample everybody is there
something I'm missing and again with
your article yes it was you haven't
hundred thousand people we did did I
miss something I definitely want to know
that but you don't want to survey them
on you know how good you I oh I'll give
you an example I'll give an example of
well I think maybe you do and I'll give
an example of why I mean let's take okay
well let's take a simple example they
did this contest for my book in December
and they all since there were three or
four book stores around the country and
they asked all the employees to guess
how many copies of The Da Vinci Code
would sell in December because and it
was interesting because the DaVinci
coders ended up selling a lot more
copies in December than double they had
expected because you know I had been out
for a long time and they thought it was
gonna run you know the pace would slow
down and in fact it continued to
accelerate so I don't know how many some
150 employees enter and the average
guess was I don't know the remember the
exact numbers within 5 percent of the
actual numbers of copies that were sold
and it was better than just about 90 was
better than 90 percent of the employees
and my suspicion is if you did that over
a series of books what you would find is
that the group guess was better than any
of the employees so now is that a
decision well I don't know if that's a
decision maybe that's just information
and that's good information but it
certainly would another example that I
talked about is a company is Eli Lilly
the drug company has set up
a spin-off called a lily which does a
lot of sort of experimental stuff and
they did this experiment where they set
up one of the ways you can do this is to
set up a kind of internal stock market
or an internal futures market and they
set up this thing where they took six
drug hypothetical drug candidates okay
and they came up with all the data you
have when you when you sort of are going
to go to the FDA for approval basically
and so they had sort of set it up so
that someone who had seen everything
from from from the inside would know
three of these drugs are going to be
approved three of these were not
basically and then they kind of gave the
they opened it up to you know employees
or scientists and some lab people in
blah blah and they open up this internal
stock market and so if you thought of if
you thought a drug was going to do well
you bought it and if you didn't you
thought you sold it and the stock market
recognized almost immediately the three
drugs that would be approved would be
approved in a three that didn't and I
mean that's a pretty concrete that's an
actionable piece of data you know you I
think you would be I actually would be
completely comfortable if I were CEO
saying these are the three drugs were
going to invest in and these are the
three we're gonna kill so but isn't that
a grenading separate pieces of data is
sort of like an investigator taking the
results of all his prospectors yes
together where it's not just opinions on
something it's people of actual
independent evidence
well is it but it's a comment but think
about it I mean I mean take the take the
da Vinci Code stuff
well isn't that somebody in my bookstore
I found that books that I like this way
shell this way so I'm gonna expand yeah
and I might be a little too low but
someone else will be higher right so
you're getting estimates from Chicago
from Torrance Adler aggregating together
no individual knows all those rounds as
well as the aggregate but don't you
think that's true I would think that
would be true of almost every decision a
corporate decision maker has to make I
mean I really I would think that that
that you know whether you're trying to
you know I mean a classic example is
mergers I mean we know that two-thirds
of all mergers fail they did say they
destroy shareholder value for the
acquiring company so it's cure I mean we
put so much faith I mean one of them one
of the parts of the book is really
talking about how you know in the 1990s
we put so much faith in the CEO
visionary CEO the decision to buy or
sell a car to buy or acquire a company
merger of the companies is the single
it's a single simplest decision not
simple in terms of the problem but in
terms of life if you make the decision
and we have a relatively good sense of
what the outcome is that a CEO is gonna
make and the most consequential in terms
of dollars and we know that two-thirds
of the time they make bad decisions so I
don't know I'm not sure the track that's
why I think the problem is I suspect the
way that companies if they ever start to
use this idea which I really wish they
would or any organization yeah Paulo I
think like government agencies is a
great example do you identify anybody
who takes advantage of politically
there's almost there's almost you know
there's very little like there are very
few examples of that of course this
summer last summer the Pentagon tried to
set up something that would potentially
have have done this which was the the
terror market and of course that was
killed basically but I think that that
had what was interesting about that was
that there were two to two markets are
going to be set up one was this external
market that anybody could join I was
gonna be open to a thousand traders but
then they were also gonna set up these
internal markets actually which would
have been open they were given two
relatively small number of people and
they would have been CIA analysts or
agents or I think some outside
specialists were gonna be invited and
and I think that had enormous promise
and the funding for both was killed
I suspect the second one they'll
probably figure out some way to bring it
back but question yeah so it sounds to
me and correct me with my interpretation
is that you're making a good argument
for good thorough market but in terms of
applying your principles or take away
coilette if corporate world yeah
business
take away would be that your your strong
component of or there's a retail value
in good market research in and as part
of that probably should be less reliance
on focus groups but also as part of that
in terms of trying to as a business to
sell things right or make things that
people want how do you factor in the so
this is a second bar the the consulate
of thought leader opinion leader right
not so much an expert for say right you
mean an opinion leader in the kind of in
the consumer market hey consuming
anything anything from a satellite to a
cookie right but I mean the kind of
person so that Malcolm Gladwell writes
about sort of in a tipping point or yeah
someone who basically other people
follow is that the someone who others
will turn to for their opinion and make
their decision based on what that right
things right well let me answer the
first part I think what I'm saying is
more complicated and saying that good
market research is is is the answer um I
think that you're definitely right that
I'm saying that focus groups are
problematic those focus groups are
especially problematic not just because
they're small but also because in small
groups unless you do a very good job of
managing the discussion what's going to
happen is that a few people are going to
take over so there's a chapter on small
groups in the book which goes in into
pretty great detail into the way the the
management the mission management team
of the space shuttle Columbia handle the
the Columbia crisis you know when the
foam smashed into the wing and you when
you when you go through what happened
you can really see the small group kind
of its decisions being made worse and
worse by each successive group meeting
basically so so I think you're right
about the focus groups in terms of the
market research I guess I'm saying
something more than that I mean it is
market research in terms of say I think
products are certainly a good idea but I
actually think the the crowd you should
be looking to is probably within your
own organization that really you want to
try to get the collective intelligence
of your organization to make these
decisions or at least to provide this
these kind of forecasts and you
Packard for example did something they
set up an internal market trying to
predict printer sales and and again it
was you know small number of people and
they were just trading on their lunch
hour and they came up with forecast that
three-quarters of the time we're better
than HP's somewhat elaborate internal
forecasting system so I think that so I
think it's a little more complicated and
I actually think that that there are
decisions they don't have to do with
products would have to do with
strategies that can be done well um the
second question is a really interesting
one and I think is one that I don't have
a clear answer to because I don't think
we really know how common or how
influential opinion leaders are I think
it's clear that people like that do
exist and I think it's clear that they
have an influence in certain areas my
suspicion is and I don't think it's
actually been clearly demonstrated on
one side or the other is that there are
some kinds of products and some kinds of
services that opinion leaders are very
important on and that there are others
that it's less important on and I
actually think the rise of the Internet
has weakened the role of the opinion
leader although people have interpreted
different ways in the sense that there
are just so many more possible sources
of information you can look to and rely
on now and I think that's a good thing
because I think the real paradox is to
the degree that opinion leaders are
influential I think that's the degree to
which collective decisions are not
necessarily bad but it's pretty much up
for grabs whether they're good or bad
because if an opinion leader can really
dictate what's what's going on then
you're talking about a very small number
of people who are and so I have a just a
section in the book about this guy named
William sellers who is this sort of the
opinion leader of the 19th century he
was this sort of nationally famous
machinist in the 1860s and he basically
is the man who invented and made
Universal the screw so the he
standardized the screw you know before
William sellers really screws didn't
we're all different you know it whoever
the tool not that the machinist you
worked with was he had his own screws
that fit his tools and sellers embarked
on this campaign a kind of classic
information cascade tipping point style
campaign and standardized the screw and
it was a good thing because the screw
was a great invention and it was a good
but what's into what scary about that
story is that if it had been a bad
design we might have been stuck with you
know bad screws for 40 years or
something
so that's a really you know that's a
kind of an open question so yeah
politicians let's say right you've got a
diverse I think I guess I have two
answers to that I mean the first is that
I think and this is a real the last
chapter in the book is about democracy
and I think it's the first one of the
first things that obviously comes from
behind I think the real problem in
thinking about politics is that it's not
clear to me that there is a true answer
about politics in the way that there's a
true answer and these other problems
that we've talked about so there's a
true answer who's gonna win the race
basically or how likely it is that a
horse will win a race there's a true
answer to the number of jellybeans or to
the I think there's a transfer to the
page that's gonna have your best the
best information and I would even say
there's a true answer to the present
value of a stock but is there a true
answer to the question should we have
gone to war in Iraq I mean true in a
this kind of metaphysical sense I don't
know it seems to me like it reflects so
many different assumptions and values
and differences that it may be that the
collectively it just it's just a
different kind of problem I had that's
what I argue in the book I think the
bigger problem with polls is that well
obviously the problem with presidential
polls is people are being asked not who
do they think will win but who will you
vote for and so you know there's this
website the Iowa electronic markets that
you could all go to and participate in
and it's it's a market and press in the
presidential election and basically you
can buy and sell it's not quite stocks
but it's very it's self-explanatory once
you get there that try to predict two
things or two markets one predicts the
vote share that each candidate will get
and the second predicts just which
candidate will win and over the last
since between 88 and 2000's been running
since 88 the markets forecasts have
outperformed polls
three quarters of the time so on days
when you had a market price and on days
when you had a poll result the markets
forecast was more accurate given the
eventual result and the eat election eve
forecasts have only been off by one
point three seven percent which is
significantly better than galas and
there it's because traders presumably
are only asking themselves who do they
think will win they have a small it's
not a major but they have a small
financial incentive to get or get it
right so you assume that some extent
cancels out the biases the other problem
with polls I think is you know is the
question of what you really want is one
number I mean an ideal situation rather
than you know rather than sort of you
know fifty five percent think this fifty
thirty eight percent this what you'd
like is some kind of you know when I
think about voting systems you'd almost
want like I always think about the MVP
vote as a the way the MVP vote is done
which is you know you vote for eight
candidates however many it is the first
gets thirteen the second gets seven but
you kind of you know you spread your
votes out so you get a sense of people's
how they weight the different choices so
I don't know politics is is it is really
difficult one I think the Iowa
electronic markets Iowa electronic
markets it's run out of the University
of Iowa and it's a real money market but
you can I think participate for that
fifty bucks
it's actually they actually got a
dispensation from the federal government
because otherwise it would be illegal in
the gambling so internet yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah if I were to decide
want to choose who I should select in
the draft I would rather use Bill James
a single individual yes and the
composite intelligence of all the scouts
out there for all the teams yes I assume
you would agree with me yes the question
is why in this particular case does it
have certain characteristics that
they're not diverse yeah I think that's
it that's the simple answer I my example
I have in the book is it's a true of
example from football if somebody it's
very similar to the problem that Mike if
any of you in a Michael in Moneyball
Michael Lewis writes the book is about
Billy Beane who is the general manager
of the Oakland A's
and over the last five years Billy Beane
applying a series of ideas about
basically about what kinds of players
are really most valuable and what kinds
of players you can get for a cheap price
because the Oakland A's have very little
money has been able to make the A's into
I think they have the second best record
overall and you know they've gone to the
playoffs four years in a row and and
they've done this despite having a
payroll that is I don't know one
fifteenth or no I think it's like yeah I
think it's one twenty-five percent of
the Yankees and and so the question is
well why I mean you know why are all
these GM's collectively so dumb roughly
speaking and the example I have in the
book is about why NFL coaches are so
cautious NFL coaches are far more
cautious in going for four first downs
on fourth down
oran going for touchdowns when they're
close to the goal line on fourth down
then they should be and we know this
because an economist named David Romer
at the University of Berk at Cal
Berkeley did a study where he basically
looked at three years of every game
every play from the NFL and what he did
was he went through and he analyzed each
spot on the field and said basically
came up with a point value what that
means is it's like if you have a if you
have the ball on the first are you have
first in first down on your 20-yard line
that's worth I don't know zero point
three points you know it means you're
gonna score only a you know a tiny
percentage whatever it is and then so he
did the math and he basically figured
out okay if you're right if you're on if
you have a fourth down and four on the
third on your opponent's 37 you should
go for it you know and why he did the
whole thing and what he found was that
NFL coaches are way too cautious and
that in of something like eleven hundred
you know opportunities it's either go
for it on fourth down or go for the
touchdown they punted or kick the field
goal 992 times so you know they're
waging options and the question is and
the question is why and I think the
answer is it that this is a classic
example where conventional wisdom is not
collective wisdom and we're you know NFL
coaches like baseball general managers
are basically drawn from the very same
pool
of candidates they approach the game
they historically have approached the
game in very similar ways I think that
the and the downside of sort of being
and in the case of the NFL coaches the
downside of being innovative seems to
outweigh the upside because one of the
things it means is in the NFL fail a
failing on fourth down is far more
visible than succeeding I think you know
it's said it's just you know if you
let's take a simple example of if you go
for the touchdown
you know Romo shows you know you should
go for the touchdown if you're gonna
succeed four out of seven times but that
means three out of seven times you're
not good you're gonna fail and you're
gonna come away with no points and
you're gonna be booed above them so so I
think that's that's an example of I
actually have a whole discussion about
this but you know I think that those are
the opportunities when sort of you know
individuals the brilliant individual can
really make a difference what's
interesting though is that after a
certain point I think the crowd will
begin and we can already see this that
the crowd has already begun to
assimilate the information I have this I
use this example of which I think it's
sort of intriguing them of this monkey
named emo who's his female monkey on an
island in Japan off the coast of Japan
who was this brilliant for some reason
just this brilliant brilliant monkey and
one of the things she had figured that
she figured out was these researchers on
the island they would give the monkeys
like wheat I guess we rands but the
wheat would get mixed in with the sand
on the beach so even but emo figured out
that if you threw if you picked up the a
handful of sand and threw it in the
little in the ocean the sand would sink
and the wheat would flow and then you
could go out and eat it and so she did
this and within you know like I don't
know a year all the monkeys were doing
it and even after the generations
continued they continued to do it so
this sort of an example of cultural
learning that's a good example of good
imitation but you know I so I think yeah
that's a you know there's a whole
section about that so um what time is it
okay yeah but in your section and
democracy
at all the initiative that we have in
several states you know where the people
legislate directly and oppress the
conventional wisdom is that the people
aren't very smart right they have to
have the representatives make the
decisions for them right I know our
reference I talked a little bit about
sort of more broadly the idea of you
know the Republican form of government I
mean I think there's probably a logic to
the logic would actually be the
something like it's it's more efficient
to have people who spend all their time
worrying about things and then trust the
crowd to do to elect those people
basically that would be the logic I
actually think a lot of the fears of
direct democracy are pretty Oken are
pretty ill-conceived and that another
way I now I'm starting to say it is if
you put the record of democracies or
Republic's in general again say you know
monarchies or dictatorships I would take
the former rather than the latter I mean
in terms of quality of decision-making
but again I think the real problem in
thinking about politics is thinking
about whether or not there's a right
answer to be uncovered I mean in some
deep deep sense and politics you know
the way I was kind of anybody's thing
about the horse race no one ever goes a
horse race and says I'm betting on this
horse no matter what because it's the
Republican horse right I mean no one
does that you bet on the horse that you
think is gonna be the most likely to win
the race but in politics the dynamic is
very different people aren't necessarily
even saying I'm gonna vote for the
candidate that is you know best for the
common good
in fact most political scientists would
say they're gonna vote for you know
who's best for me and and unlike and say
the market where I think you know those
individual acts of self-interest cannot
be aggregated in something larger it's
not clear in a democracy it works that
way so a couple one yeah
the case of politics and democracy you
have the enormous factor of groups of
people or organizations behind the in
Soviet decision whereas in the corporate
setting there's not anybody spending
millions of dollars to have their
product chosen that leader the other
problems right no I think I think that's
another thing that makes it a lot of
ways organized politics that do
everything you can to mean right no I
think that I think that's I think that's
true that the the sheer amount of money
obviously that's invested the authority
that you know certain people have and
others don't
I mean the truth is politics does play a
role I think within corporations yeah
and I actually think that one of the
reasons why these kinds of
decision-making mechanisms are
potentially useful within corporations
is that they allow companies to
circumvent those sort of political you
know where people are like well you know
what this product is the best one for
the company probably but but this is the
one that was gonna you know get me that
promotion so let's go with this one um
but but yeah I think you know on the
political scene the question of
propaganda or just more generally the
barrage of of advertising which isn't
really I think diverse in any sense is
is a huge challenge so between you get
one more alright one more sorry
yeah corrected saying that this was an
idealized example yeah and I as a
scientist I think of science is actually
a more of an example of crowds making
poor decisions right and with very
strong adverse effects of information
cascades well tell me a little bit more
about why you think that are you talking
about within the scientific community I
think if you do within the scientific
community if you asked scientists what's
your current view but what's the
scientific community's view on truth to
some facts right more often than not I
think those views are wrong and they are
later proved to be incorrect right facts
emerged and I think that much of that in
correctness is due to information
cascades right because we have different
bits of information emerging at
different times because it's sort of
sequential rather than simultaneous is
like that and but what's juggling and I
raise the question of how the time
component factors into decisions and how
you consider well that's actually your
second question I mean I think that
that's something I probably didn't I
didn't think about that that much in
terms of science and and I think that
obviously and you also have the opinion
leader problem in science as well which
is what I talked about at the end of the
chapter which is this strange phenomena
you know the strange phenomenon of you
know the the better-known you are the
more sighted you are pretty much
guaranteed and there's this great
example of the story of the Richard
Lewontin who's this sort of well known
geneticist co-wrote this article and
with caring for the other guy was a
geneticist as well anyway they co-wrote
these two articles and in one of them
wants his name was first and in the
second one the other guy's name was
first and see I can't remember the other
guy's name which is exactly example of
this and and the one with lots his name
first was has been cited vastly more
because people assumed that he had
really written now and so that must be
the one that really counts basically so
I think that's an issue I think time is
is a fundamental problem though at least
in general and decision making and I
think I sort of talked about this in in
the chapter on independence that that
that the best and the prom in science I
suppose is that you to help you can't
really tell people hold back they're in
for me
until you know we have a better sense of
the collective because that is you know
part of just how scientific progress
occurs I suppose is by things being
disproved but I think in general if you
can set up situations in which people
are making decisions all at once rather
than sort of taking their cues from the
people that come before them you end up
with with far better decisions it's not
an easy thing to do but I do think that
it's the benefits of it are immense if
you can do that so alright I guess we
should go thank you all for coming
thanks for the questions and I hope you
like the book
James Surowiecki writes the financial
page column for The New Yorker the
wisdom of crowds is published by
doubleday is that Doubleday calm for
more information